hello everyone thank you for joining we
would be starting the session in just
five more minutes we are waiting for
others to join as well
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for the webinar today on a very
exciting topic that is spaceomics
that is dedicated to the study of omix
data to study molecular mechanisms
affected by the space travel and
critical for astronaut health as well
so as we have a lot of new participants
joining us today i would like to first
of all introduce what space omix is all
about and then we listen to the mentors
discussing about the various research
project opportunities in the domain
itself
so astrobiology is a science which
addresses the origin of life on earth
and potential for life elsewhere in the
universe as well
space flight is one of the most extreme
conditions that has been encountered by
humans
and advances in our mix methodology such
as genomics transcriptomics proteomics
and metabolomics have revealed that
unique differences exist between
individuals
these differences can be amplified in
extreme conditions such as space flight
a better understanding of individual
differences may allow us to develop
personalized counter measure packages
that optimize the safety and performance
of each astronaut
radiation microgravity altered
atmospheric gas composition isolation
and dye changes are just some of the
known stressors affecting humans in the
space environment
with extended mission durations and
distances outside of the earth's orbit
these factors are expected to increase
there are several adverse human health
effects associated with space flight
including bone demineralization skeletal
muscle atrophy cardiovascular
deconditioning vestibular control immune
system suppression and neuro ocular
ailments as well
so it is critical to understand how
space flight factors affect human health
in order to develop space
safe and effective counter measures
the nasa twin study catalyzed the need
for more comprehensive consortium-based
approaches to study the long-term
effects of space flight on humans here a
nine research group studied a single
data type in detail which another group
performed multi-organic synthesis
to determine the whole body changes the
study identified alterations in numerous
data types including telomere length
gene regulation gut microbiome
composition body weight carotid artery
dimensions and serum metabolite profiles
as well
so before we start with the talk i would
like to introduce us we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy-to-use
analytical tools and our mission here is
to make bioinformatics more accessible
omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10 000 users around
the world and due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine local program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
as well adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world
my name is sunali khari and i'm the
omixlogic community manager and
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of
our bioinformatics community managed by
biotech
our training is designed to allow
participants to apply methods to curated
and new data sets
and develop independent projects that
showcase what has been learned in the
context of a personal portfolio of
projects
as a result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project of their own
so together with our existing modules
for which you will gain access to the
omixlogic portal where you can try and
explore these modules exercises and
pipeline building coding and various
methods of analysis using projects
resources from peer-reviewed
publications
now i would like to pass on the stage to
subrajeed barwan delara dicken to talk
about their astrobiology projects and
experience as well
subraject barua is an ms in molecular
biology and biotechnology at the
international scamp laboratory itamo
university saint pittsburgh russia he is
a graduate of red school 2021 latex
french exobiology society
he is an astrobiology educator at art of
inquiry where he works closely with
julia brodsky former nasa iess astronaut
trainer he is also a volunteer at mars
on earth project where he works on
margin projects he is a russian
government open door scholar and a
president scholarship awardee as well he
was also one of the top 10 students
globally selected for sgac space health
risk symposium london 2021
we are pleased to have you with us
subrajeet over to you
thank you so much
for
that wonderful
presentation
and
hello to everyone who has joined us
today
it's lovely to see you all here and
[Music]
as sonalika
very accurately mentioned that we are
going to
indulge more into this
wonderful topic of astrobiology or
spaceomics and i'm pretty much sure that
every one of you who is present here
today is
interested and enthusiastic and you're
well aware of the various kinds of
research going on around the world
there are also numerous opportunities
which are early career as well as
for the more experienced ones
be it a postdoctoral fellow or
a scientist position available for
various people all across the globe to
grab this opportunity
to help people do that and
announce yourself in the domain of
astrobiology we at find biotech have
organized this particular opportunity
for all of you where
every one of you can get an opportunity
to indulge in your own independent as
well as team
projects
where you would also receive
mentor support one-on-one guidance and
available course materials which would
help you to learn all along the way as
you go
and if you have joined us for the first
time there was another webinar which was
done and in that webinar me and my
colleagues have
discussed in detail about
what are the topics that we are going to
cover what is astrobiology all about
what is our focus and what is our aims
and in today's
webinar which is more of like a
discussion we would be discussing about
all the project ideas that you guys have
and what are your aspirations
we would also
discuss about potential teams you guys
can form teams amongst yourself those
who are already here or if you have a
research lab or a team who would be
interested you can also invite them and
today we will be discussing about where
to find the data sets what the data
looks like and how can you
start your own project just by sitting
at your home
this is a pandemic
era where it's very difficult to get
hold of a laboratory to go to the fields
and do the research work
same thing kind of problem everyone is
facing all around the world but we can't
stop right we have to go on doing our
own projects and
coming up with the publication
participating in conferences and
therefore this sort of a model where you
can actually get involved in
practical works right from your home
remotely provides you an exciting
opportunity to be a part of bigger
consortiums and groups just by sitting
at your home
so before i move on to the further
discussions i would like to show you
guys about
what the entire plan is how it looks
like and
what is
the plan all together so i guess you
guys can see my screen so this is the
home page of the program which is called
introduction to space comics
and this program is actually designed
you to help you through your research
project now there are several
steps in defining a project and getting
it done for example it begins with
finding a good data set a data set which
is worthy of looking deeper into to
curate it to label it properly and to
make it ready the second part
is obviously the analysis part
the methodologies that you have to use
and how you're going to use it
what is the appropriate methods that you
should
apply for your expected results
now once you get the hold of the results
how do you understand if the results are
a good result or a bad one or what do
you biologically interpret from those
data and how can it correlate with
whatever
is happening happening or going on in
the biological body
so
these are the various challenges which
many students face in today's world
whatever background you belong and
whatever your expertise might be these
are the problems are the challenges
which most of the people face and that's
why we have designed this particular
curriculum to help you understand what
we are going to talk about and what is
it all about
so to begin with the first day would be
focused towards the topic of
astrobiology what is it all about what
are the various subtypes as you can see
on this screen
we will be also discussing about the
theories of origin of life
and
the various topics or debates currently
going on in this particular domain
the next day which is on october 25th we
would be
diving deeper into
the concept of origin of life because i
am sure that many of you are interested
in actually analyzing or understanding
the origin of life better and you want
to start some projects of your own use
in this particular aspect of origin of
life
so we would give you some idea about how
you can
gather data what sort of data should you
look into what are the concepts that you
can analyze definitely we would be
talking about extremo files because
you all must agree that
extrema files are
very very important
in the understanding of origin of life
or not as well as in the concept of
hoping for life beyond earth
and we would just not give you another
lecture but also give talk about the
data sets how does it look like where
you can find them and also give you
certain project examples
which uses ancient rna construction or
protein remodeling and
what results have they got and what can
you guys do as a part of your project
and this is not something which is very
rare like many research groups are
actually doing
marvelous research in this particular
domain
then the third
day would be focused more towards the
other aspect of astrobiology which is
space flight travel
so as you would agree that
in the current ada with the commercial
space flight agencies coming to the
forefront
traveling to space has increased
manifolds
and with the increase in the number of
missions to space the risks of
astronauts getting affected by the
various factors of space flight is also
increasing rapidly for example space
flight is made up of various factors
like
microgravity ionizing radiation
and isolation that has an effect on
their brain
so
before we plan a mission to mars or
maybe even the moon which are long-term
missions it becomes mandatory to
completely understand the effects of
these conditions on
the genome and
the expression of genes the gut
microbiome of the astronauts and
we need to make sure that they won't
suffer from any chronic illness like
cancer when they are on that particular
mission
to do that it's the right time to
actually get hold of these sort of data
sets and
start analyzing them and believe me or
not there are various organizations in
the world who are looking into this
particular domain and they want people
to get involved in this sort of
projects
uh to give you an example there's
one conference which is coming up next
month and it's focused towards space
health and the peaceful use of space
technologies
so you can understand by the title
itself that people are all around the
world are actually talking about this
particular thing so it's a best
opportunity for us to get involved in
these sorts of conferences and other
opportunities by having a project of our
own
so that's what we will be talking about
and on the fourth day
since find biotech
focuses on bioinformatics how to utilize
the various comics data to your project
we would be giving you a thorough
explanation of all the omics levels like
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and also multiomics
integration
this
omics levels were studied in the nasa
twin study as mentioned by salah
but here's the benefit of doing it with
us
first first of all you don't need to
have any coding skills many students who
are biologists like me have a problem
with coding
that's a big hurdle but here you don't
need to code why
because here you would get all the
algorithms just
in a point and click interface
so you don't need to know about any of
these algorithms what's behind that what
are the codes you just have to see this
particular user interface which prompts
you helps you with
every detail which pops up on the screen
and you just have to click point and
click and you can build the entire
pipeline i will be giving you other
examples as well
and show you how to do it
and
excuse me
so the final day that is the day five
would be again focused towards uh
projects because that's the day when you
guys need to come up or decide on your
projects and finalize what are you going
to working work on from this particular
day so this day i would be giving you
other examples of projects and
walking you through my project how i do
it how i did it and what are
what my project looks like even today i
would be showing you some examples
and on this day we will discuss with you
all your confusions or doubts and
from this particular day you would get
the opportunity to work on your own
project and you would be meeting the
mentors twice a month
so you would be getting the support you
can show them all your results consult
with them and that final target of
course is to come up with a good result
which you can
publish if it is excellent
if not publishing just now you can
definitely take it to a conference
as a poster or an oral presentation
so
let me give you an example of the
various projects that has been already
done by the people who have participated
in the previous programs so as you can
see here this is my project here
and if i scroll down you would see that
various other people have submitted
their projects which they have completed
with mine so you can see these research
questions and they are the ones which
are going around in the world of biotech
right now so
here you can see the in silico analysis
of affected biological pathways in
multiple sclerosis transcriptomic
analysis of cd4 plus t cells so
every
project that has been done here has been
either published in a peer reviewed
journal or has been taken to a
conference and
several students have won several prizes
in fact
so let me walk you through one of the
projects and show you how it looks like
so the project here if you go through
you would find that it's a
well-structured interface where you
would find a brief overview you will
find details about the data sets you can
check it out
and these are all submitted to the
harvard repository you can visit them
and analyze them yourself
then comes the abstract part where you
would explain your project in brief as
you guys know the structure of a
peer-reviewed journal paper basically is
similar
so once you submit your project in this
particular manner over here
it gets very easy to take it to a
publication or to take it to any
conference because everything that you
need is ready
so it looks really interesting right
so before we move on to you guys and
discuss with you what are your interests
and i will also show you some
techniques to analyze it
and some pipelines that i have created
but before moving on to that we have
with us
from turkey and she has been one of
those participants whom about whom i was
talking about and she has
already done a project in this
particular domain of astrobiology where
she has analyzed the radiation threats
and the effects of radiation ionizing
radiation on the microbiome of
astronauts
and
she has also taken her
project to a preprint publication and
i'm sure she is looking for submitting
it into a peer-reviewed journal so
it's the best opportunity to have a look
and learn from her have a look at her
project and learn from her how was her
experience of the project how did she
utilize the platform of divine foe in
pain and
what's this what's her entire experience
because it's a similar kind of
experience that you guys are also going
to experience in just a few days so hi
dilara
over to you now
hello thank you for that introduction
and i will quickly share my screen
one second
i hope everyone can see clearly
so um so bridgette said i'm dilara and
i'm a former oxylogic research fellow
and i'll be taking you through the
process of conducting research on astro
science using genome using omics through
the t bioinfo platform
um
first i will tackle some key points in
research like how to come up with a
hypothesis where and how to find good
data and how to convince an audience
that your research is relevant and
important then i will take you through
my research and show which data and
graphs are best to present and which
ones i chose
and we will even practice one a pipeline
practically
so the hypothesis could be the start of
your research or vice versa for me the
purp and for the purposes of my research
i decided to start
uh here so while i was reading articles
to find a topic that intrigued me
i came upon the gut brain access and
since my preferred field was
astrobiology i decided to study how the
gut microbiome affects the the nervous
system of astronauts
my hypothesis was based on
how high led linear energy transfer
ionizing radiation
affected the nervous system of
astronauts
my hypothesis was based on this type of
radiation for several reasons like the
fact that it causes chemical reactions
i surmise that this type of radiation
would have
adverse effects on the human body and
the gut microbiome
now
on to finding a good data set
you can actually search for articles
that are published in high impact factor
and well-known arctic
well-known journals because they are
very well peer reviewed
very rigorously peer reviewed and you
should also try to pick ones with high
sample numbers
uh since you can get better results and
machine learning um techniques with uh
huge numbers of samples
as you can see mine was categorized um
based on the radiation and time and i
had 80 samples
and of course you can search ncbi and
some other platforms like jgi for
microbiome data and as for the pipeline
it is important to
choose an appropriate preprocessing and
processing method since you have a lot
of data that you have to filter through
when you have um huge amounts of data
and you can do this using the tbi info
server so if you would like we can try a
hands-on example and then i can take you
through which graphs i chose from those
results
um and then
we can
continue like that so i guess the link
is already in the
chat so if you can quickly go there
and you will come to this page where
there are numerous
different areas of analysis
and from my um type of data i chose
amplicon 16 18
because of
the type of data that was in the article
was 16 is rrna data
so here you can see a demo
and if you are following with me
we can here you can see as well
pre-processing for this demo there isn't
pre-processing but for my art for my
data there was
which helps remove
primers etc
and here we are trying
um
all of them i hope everyone can see
because i can't see the chat right now
so if you have any problems please let
me know
and what is great is the the dota 2
pipeline here and the final seek
pipeline you can run them both together
at the same time
and then
here you can see
um i will pick this one the other two
and final c plots pdf
and if you go there
here you can see the abundance plot here
a heat map
showing the differences in the
abundances
um a phylogenetic tree showing both the
abundances as well here the shannon
index that i will be explaining in
detail
and
here we have uh nmds plots um so you can
go through those in your free time if
you would like and now i'll go back to
the
to my data specifically
and show you
uh so basically
my ngs data which is the 16s rn rrna
data was collected from tc samples of
mice exposed to different types of two
four different doses of radiation and
these samples were collected at 10 days
and 30 days post radiation
so from these results i decided to pick
the nmds plot which is a non-metric
multi-dimensional analysis plot
which is a data reduction technique
which means that you can
input high amounts of data and it will
the machine learning um
algorithm will filter through this data
and it will only give you the points
which have a great variance and have a
great effect on the data
so you can see here um
at
the differences between the groups and
at 10 days post radiation that group is
slightly more separated than the others
so the next output that i chose was
the shannon index
since it gives us a general idea about
the richness and evenness of bacteria in
the samples
it is a great plot because it summarizes
everything the alpha diversity the
better diversity of the microbiome and
here you can see that for lower doses of
radiation like 0.1 and 0.25 gui the
diversity decreases more compared to the
control group
so
next i decided to use the phylogenetic
tree
and uh
this one has a bonus because we can see
the abundances based on the categories
as well as you can see the otus that
have a great effect as here the
algorithm filtered those out for us so
otu 3 4 and 5 are the ones that i'll be
focusing on in the next step and here
you can also see that for 0.1 gy at 10
days it has the greatest decrease in
abundance compared to zero gui
to corroborate the results i also
conducted a t-test and an f-test on
excel
and uh using the t-bind for server again
in the utility section you can even
generate heat maps
and that's why it's really great using
this platform because i didn't know
coding
very well and
i can't say i'm very efficient at it
yet so
you don't need to know these things you
can directly start
generating graphs without knowing how to
code using this platform
so i generated this heat map and as you
can see all the graphs that i use
are the graphs that summarize large sums
of data
which is helpful when explaining a new
concept to an audience
here you can see the difference in
abundances for otu 3 4 5 and 8.
they are significantly decreased between
0.1 and 0gy
i then decided to search the keg
database
for these four otus
um because i didn't have names exactly
so and they corresponded to
lactobacillus and buy for the bacterium
genus and i found out that these have
protein coding genes in the gaba pathway
gaba is gamma aminobutyric acid and it
is a chief neurotransmitter in the scent
in the central nervous system and causes
depression and anxiety when in low doses
so we can conclude that lower doses of
radiation especially 0.1 gui collected
at 10 days post radiation
the abundances of these four types of
bacteria decrease the most and since
they have they produce gaba we can say
that it has a correlation to the
depression anxiety that astronauts
suffer during long-term flights
and that my initial hypothesis about the
gut brain axis is also correct of course
further research is required but this is
a good precursor study and probiotics
can help alleviate some of the symptoms
of these astronauts
so what did i learn personally
during this project submission and while
conducting this research
first of all um
i learned how to sort through good data
and find a good quality articles
and you become more efficient at
creating a narrative so that your
readers and listeners can understand
your research the more you write the
better you get at it and especially
referring to your mentors during this
stage is great because they will
help you throughout the process and you
can
efficiently estimate the quality of the
data as well
and then you will come out also knowing
which graphs are best to recapitulate
your data and how to summarize your
research and overall
if you are rigorous during this
stage
you can also learn how to conduct
scientific data in an excellent manner
so here are my references and if you
have any questions feel free to ask me
you can inquire anytime
and thank you for listening to me i'll
pass it back to
well subrajeet you so much it was an
amazing presentation i i'm sure that all
of you would agree that
the steps that she had explained the
manner in which she could
start her journey from a data set which
she got from the publicly available
domain like ncbi
to actually get some
good data results which are biologically
interpretable and has some meaning
is what we
all want to do it but
as you would also notice that there are
certain terms there are certain
concepts or certain
graphs which you might need some help to
interpret and at this moment you might
not be aware of all those terminologies
as such and
that is one of the reasons why we have
organized or designed this particular
course
where we would be helping you to
understand all those concepts before you
start working on your own project
so by the end of this particular program
you would have a clear understanding of
all the terms that we have used you
would have a clear understanding of
the what's the pipeline and what kind of
a strategy you need to follow to get
hold of your results
at the same time
during the course of your project you
would also get
help from mentors you would get their
advices you would get your consultations
so you would be able to consult the
mentors look for answers and get
guidance from them as you go along it's
not that we would leave you after the
program is over to explore on your own
definitely you would have an opportunity
to work independently but also you would
get the support so before i move on to
some other project examples and show you
how
the entire thing works from scratch
i would love to know what are your
interests so it would be great if you
head down to the chat section
and write down as vaguely as possible
what's your interest of research or
what's the absolute
field of astrobiology which excites you
the most you can also write it like
i'm interested in origin of life i'm
interested in exoplanet hunting i'm
interested in space health
so it's completely up to you and i would
love to see some responses in the chat
right now about what
particular aspect of astrobiology
interests you and what would you love to
indulge more upon you can also
write down what are your
other interests in general or what are
you currently studying
your degree or level of education and
maybe i would be able to guide you
better
about
what you might select as your project
so guys feel free to write down in the
chat whatever comes to your mind
i won't be judging you i would just
indulge in a conversation and show you
that
what's the area where you can start
and how far you are from your own
project
okay i'm waiting for your responses you
can just write it in short only to
explain it
uh long
and i hope that you are able to hear me
in the first place
and
if i don't get any responses right now i
would like to pick you up and ask you
about your interests one by one
would you prefer that
okay
so here i see one response from
so she is interested in issue
regeneration in space
so ruth
you might be studying about issues
regeneration
like you might have done some literature
review
or you might be looking into this
particular aspect and you know that what
are the various signatures that people
study and what are the various
challenges now you are interested to
study that in
how tissue regeneration happens on space
because i'm sure that you have this
particular idea that how regenerative
tissue would be utilized to help with
the astronauts when they're on a
long-term mission to help them heal to
help them
maybe do some surgery or patch so that's
a really really cool
project that you have
yeah surgery in space right so i got you
right so that's a very interesting
project and then so the first thing that
you need to do in order to start or get
started is find a good data set
to look for data sets and that's
something which i would show you a
little bit today as well as in depth
during the course during the program we
would guide you and also once the
program is over we would also guide you
to get hold of a good data set up for
your own a data set which is good free
from noise and also
well
like well classified and categorized for
the particular project so i also see
zahara about asking about the bacteria
in space so
you know there's two things which comes
to my mind and i would
require a clarification from you first
one are you asking for the bacteria
which
might exist
on other planets or other places about
the international space station or you
mean the bacterium which we carry or the
astronauts carry with themselves in
their gut microbiome in the gut
to space and what happens to those
bacteria you see there's two really
interesting equally interesting aspects
of this particular question and
it would be interesting to know which
one you are more interested about i can
also add in a third
which would be focused more about um
how
a person or an astronaut might respond
to bacterium in space
so
we might assume that immune system might
be affected and i will show you some
examples of some results from data which
does hint at
the weakening of
immune system when one travels to space
so how does he respond to bacterium and
if he gets a infection in space then
how can he combat with it and what are
the ways in which we can address that so
sarah means gut microbiome
and
that is similar to what
de lara had also focused on so
when you go to space
there's various factors which affects
you there's microgravity
there's ionizing radiation you
i mean the astronauts survive on a
different kind of a diet which is
pre-processed so now
this particular
factors have their own kind of effect or
a combined effect on the gut microbiome
and as we all know that gut microbiome
plays an important role in many things
including immunity it has a connection
with the gut brain axis just like dilara
mentioned so it could also have defects
on your central nervous system and maybe
that can cause some neurodegeneration
which would be harmful so what are the
ways in which we can actually address
those issues would be interesting to
look into and
therefore your entire topic is very
relevant and interesting i also see
india he has mentioned that
t cell function
is impacted you're absolutely right and
microbes are also more viral
i mean the microbes
activity gets more viral and it affects
more so
i think you can look
much more into in deeper in this
particular field because um
t cell has various function t cell has
various categories as you might know
there's t helper cells there cytotoxic t
cells
now it would be interesting to know what
factors affect them and what are the
pathways which are affected as a result
of the t cell
dysregulations
and what are the ways which we can which
we can address them can we identify some
particular targets which can be
addressed or targeted with some drugs
and therefore make the future astronauts
well prepared or cubed to actually
combat all of these issues
so here are certain very interesting
project ideas already like even before
the course has started and before you i
have introduced you to the various
interesting aspects there's already so
many interesting project ideas
so
this is something which i was actually
talking about and
it would be very interesting to know
more so all of you guys for those who
are here in the audience
keep typing keep writing and even if you
don't have a topic it's absolutely fine
there's nothing to worry about because
we have certain project ideas that i
would like to share with you then also
join me in my team and i would love to
work with you and we can together
explore
the various secrets which are hidden
so now i would like to show you
one particular example which i am
looking into right now
and
i would show you from scratch how i
proceeded and how i went on
so here's my browser so
i wanted to analyze what happens to the
immune system of the astronauts when
they go to space
but you would agree that human generated
data is limited but that's okay so
where to look for data ncbi is one very
good place to look for data the other
one for
specifically designed for
all of astrobiological work is nasa gene
now so here i'm going and i will also
give you the link
in the chat so you all can visit it
yourself as well
so nasa gene labs is a open source data
repository where
the data from each and every space
missions which are in collaboration with
this particular organization have
submitted so you can see here various
transactions databases genomics
proteomics various of the processed data
you can also get a
hang of all the publications that has
been done
so
i went to this particular repository
i
went to
the data repository section and i
started to look into
various organisms here you can see
there's this particular study which
talks about the effect of microgravity
on
epigenetic modifications of senior
hepatitis elegance and stuffs
i focused my study on
mouse so i went and
looked for mass musculus
so here you can see mouse
i
use the filter mouse to get all the
mouse data
and
i
come across various mouse data which has
been studied uh you can also filter the
various acid types for example dna
methylation profiling or genome
sequencing transcriptome profiling so
these are the radius terms which i would
be explaining you during the course of
the program and by the end of it you
would get a hang of all what it is if
you already aren't aware of it i'm sure
many of you already know about it so
here you can see marine t cell receptor
beta repertoire sequencing so someone i
guess india was talking about um
t cell receptors so here you can see
there is data for t cell receptor
sequences so you can analyze them and
get involved more so let me go to the
particular data set that i used and the
number
accession number for it is glds288
so it is the transcriptome analysis of
mouse spleen
if you open this particular
site you would get
the details of the mission
in a very well structured manner you
would get all the
[Music]
all the protocols that were done and
what is the various aspects of this data
what how would you define them what are
the metadata about the data sets what
were the conditions basically what were
the sexes what was the age of them
and more
so i will show you how it looks like
when you download this data set
and load it on to excel
so we will be using excel a lot so get
ready to use excel profoundly
and don't worry
we would also cover it in the program
and also you would find some free
materials on the omixlogic platform
which talks about
how to use excel and how you can get a
hold of everything on excel
all right so here you can see that there
were three categories of samples
the first which were cultured in a
centrifuge but in one gravity like the
normal gravity that we are used to
and this is the main control
that we have so centrifuge is done just
to replicate the stress on the organism
then we have the ground control
which does nothing to the
mouse
mouse models they are just
normally on the ground
and the third one
where the actual mice which went to
space aboard spacex dragon
a capsule and they spent around 35 days
aboard the international space station
and then they were brought to earth
so now you have various genes which you
can identify here with their gene ids
but we want to look at the signatures we
want to identify which genes might be
affected and what does that
show or what does that mean to us
so that's where the platform of t by
info comes handy
if you look at my pipeline here which i
used
so i used a pipeline which is known as
the differential gene expression
pipeline
and here you can see all the algorithms
that are involved in this particular
pipeline and i just use three of them so
when you click on start you go to the
differential expression algorithm
because dc2 enrichment analysis gene set
enrichment analysis unless the end
and once this pipeline ran for some
amount of time it gave me various
results so here are
all the results that it generated that's
a lot but it's also
very interesting to look into all of
these results so
once i downloaded all these results here
you can see
now we can actually open some of these
plots and diagrams and have a look at
what
it means and what are the various
interesting pathways that we can look
into
first of all we get some volcano plots
this is known as a volcano plot it's
basically shows whether there are
certain genes which are highly
upregulated or down regulated
and
amongst them which are the most
interesting ones so you can see some of
the names of genes here so you have the
evidence that yeah something is going
wrong when these mice visit space
next up
you would see this particular plot which
is a graph and it shows that which genes
are
co-expressed in various paths here are
various pathways and some genes are
involved in more than one pathways
and in this particular
amongst this particular pathways in
which pathway is this particular gene
highly regulated expressed or low
expressed down regulated or upregulated
and you can identify them and you can do
further analysis
also there's this particular plot which
shows which pathways might be affected
and upregulated or down regulated and
you would find some very interesting
pathways like activation of immune
response myeloid cell homeostasis
response to bacterium
erythrocytes homeostasis complement
activation the complement pathway
activation iodine homeostasis psychosis
recognition
and more so you can understand that
with the help of a few clicks only
you could get insight into so many
different biological pathways which are
affected how they are affected what's
the amount by which they are affected
and from here
you can go on and study their
interactions as well
for these networks how these genes are
connected with each other what networks
do they form and amongst this particular
network what are the genes that are
interesting to look into
so there are various pathways that you
can look into some of these networks are
very very complex but it's still
very much informative
so
with the help of this particular data
and with the help of the other data that
are generated i would also like to show
you what we can do it with the
differentially expressed genes
so this is how the differential gene
expression actual data looks like on
excel
and if i do a count here so there are
currently 17 907 genes
but not all of them are interesting to
me why because not all of them might be
significant
so how to set a filter for significance
so we have to set parameters in the log
to full change and let's set it between
two
and minus two
so it should be greater than or equal to
minus two and less than or equal to two
so that along change of two would be a
significant one we can also set some
filters for p value and the adjusted
value
this stands for the benjaminian horchman
threshold value we usually set it to
0.05
and we can also
finally apply one
sorting and sort it from lowest to
highest
so now for example let's look at the
first gene that it shows by the way
remember we had 17907 genes to begin
with but now we just have 40 genes so
now our
data set is much more refined and
polished we just have 40 significantly
affected genes which would be
interesting to look into and see how are
they getting affected and what does that
mean
so the first one the first gene here uh
has some crazy id but don't worry once
you run it in the platform on the pine
barrack platform you would get the
name and the symbol of the platform and
you can guess what it does it's
hemoglobin beta at a key chain so you
get a hold of what this particular gene
is and what it might do
uh what it might do so you can also go
and explore more in
ncbi to learn more about them
so once you select this particular genes
and you would like to do a plot right
here
to see how are they affected so here you
go
so you see the first
three samples as you might see here are
microgravity
or the samples or the genes in the mouse
which went to space
as compared to the other three which
were on earth in a centrifuge so clearly
you would see that the three samples the
first three samples
have suffered a down regulation of this
particular gene
and they are suppressed whereas the
other three are high
like maybe they are expressing normally
without being affected that we don't
know yet but what's interesting is that
these three have suffered a down
regulation now what does this down
regulation mean
so that would be interesting to look
into further that what does the down
regulation of this particular gene
have the effect on the
phenotype of the organism does it cause
some pathways to go wrong or something
like that
and
the pathway that i use the pipeline that
i used also generates something known as
pathway enrichment analysis and this
result also gives us
the names of the pathways which are
affected so here you can see pi 3k akt
signaling pathway calcium signaling
pathway the spliceosome
axon guidance and immediately when i
look into these names what i'm reminded
of is molecular neuroscience because all
of these pathways are
important
in neuronal activity but we used steam
tissue for our sequencing
and now that we are getting some hint at
the pathways that are affected in the
spleen
they are affecting both the immune
system as well as the nervous system or
the central nervous system now it would
be interesting to look further that how
does this particular pathways going
wrong in the spleen can have an effect
on the brain and if it is so then maybe
the people who
go on a space travel actually might
suffer from some form of
neurodegeneration in the future
they might have or develop some
neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's disease or
schizophrenia or something like that
so this is the entire thing where you
would like to reach as the end goal of
your crowd project and if you actually
reach into something of this sort
definitely you would be able to publish
it or take it to a conference and talk
more about it and discuss with other
experts about what does these results
mean and what are the effects of these
results
so
[Music]
that's what i showed you
and now i would like to
ask you
uh i would like to give you the floor to
ask any questions that you might have to
me about this particular project
or about the entire program
and this is something which we want to
achieve with you guys as well
and when you enroll for the program we
would first guide you about all these
terms let me show you one more thing as
well
um when you go to the omixlogic platform
you would find that there is an option
called courses
and if you go to the courses section
here you would also find see various
courses which are free like introduction
to bioinformatics and other stuffs
specifically you can also go to
transcriptomics for example from this
tabs here because i was talking about
transcriptomics
you would be interested into looking at
how
or what are the various projects and the
various courses that are available on
the platform
um i would also show you something else
just get
give me one moment
to find out
so here's one very interesting and free
course that is available on the platform
itself it's called the bytes and
molecules
so i would recommend you to go through
this for sure you would understand what
we are talking about we would understand
what is the dna what is dna rna and what
what are we looking into it how are we
looking into it and
finally in the end you would also find
the last course that is space omics and
astronaut health so this is a course
which has been specifically designed for
this particular course where if i show
you
you would learn a lot about this
particular domain you would learn a lot
about what's going on what's suggested
by nasa what's
what we mean by microgravity what are
the various methods of simulating
microgravity and
there what are the videos data
repositories like i was showing you nasa
gene labs you can see and go through how
nasa gene labs look like
and what is it
so uh there's one more thing which i
would like to show you is
the transcriptomics course
if you go here
you see this is a very
nice and
classy explanation of what transmitomics
is and it basically explains everything
that i did in my project and i was
talking to you and showing you you see
there's next generation sequencing
explained here what is what does the
data look like and what are the various
algorithms that you might use
here to analyze
your own data set similarly you would
also find courses about genomics about
metagenomics so whatever your interest
might be
whatever is it that you are interested
in you can definitely go through these
courses on your own without us
intervening at all and look
up
on your own understand about
what is it and
how you can apply or implement these
things in your own project so here also
you can see uh rnseq the pipeline has
been explained you are also getting a
practical to do the rnseq practical here
and also then there's other statistical
tests like the t-test
uh you will also learn about
differential gene expression you see i
was showing you certain results of this
sort this particular
graph or plot so it's explained in this
particular course about how to interpret
it what it is how it looks like there's
other machine learning algorithms as
well like the unsupervised machine
learning algorithm of pca
and more
so
this particular course is not free as
you can see there's a star here but to
all the participants who registered for
the program you would get access to all
these particular courses and more about
the payment ways and how you can do it
and what are the benefits of it what are
the various slabs
a
subscription that you can avail would be
explained by sonalika so
now i would pass on the platform to
sonalika to explain and guide you
through all the payment stuffs and what
are the benefits what are the courses
that you can access which are otherwise
paid but now you can
access it because you have the
subscription for this particular course
and meanwhile if you guys have any
question out of the blue whatever it
might be doesn't matter put them in the
chat section and i would be happy to
address them
so over to you
thank you so much
for
such a wonderful presentation of the
project and whatever you worked on and
also the way you explained your results
was amazing and thank you so much to
lara as well for your explanation of the
project
and
now for those who have not registered
themselves for the program but
interested to do so so they can find the
link to the program page in the chat box
that uh has just been shared by ojasmi
so here on the program page you would be
able to find all the details of the
sessions which are scheduled for the
program
the calendar shows all the dates on
which the sessions are scheduled and
also the topics that are going to be
covered
for the program
now here on the program page itself you
would be able to find the zoom links
sessions once you are a part of this
page and also once the session is over
you would find the recording of that
particular session on the page itself
and you can just go to the recording at
your own pace now mania like many times
what happens the person is not available
at the live session uh time duration so
for you it would be very easy to uh to
just go through the recording and take
up doubts in the uh common slack channel
that we use for communication
and uh to register yourself for the
program on the registration page itself
you would find three levels beginner
intermediate and advanced now these
three levels are actually differentiated
just based on the facilities that are
being provided for the uh program
right so here uh in the intermediate
level you have the access to one-on-one
mentor support where you can have uh one
live session uh with your mentor or like
a one-on-one meeting for 60 minutes and
also then we have the advanced license
where you will get extra time to work on
a project one-on-one mentor support
would definitely be there and also the
license to the uh server would be the
research license whereas in case of the
pregnant and the intermediate ones it
would be an educational license
so that is the difference between three
levels whichever level you would like to
enroll yourself you can just select this
uh the option and just proceed with the
payment gateway
now there is one thing there are many uh
countries or areas where the
international banking is
not active for the participant so you
also have alternate options and you can
just mail us at marketing either at pine
dot bio and we can just share out the
alternate option details with you it
would be a paypal link and also for
indians you can
use the bank transfer option directly or
the gpa or the other modes of internet
payment
and also on the program page itself you
would be able to find the program course
and project libraries to which you will
have the access on the portal
now these are the asynchronous course
materials that you are supposed to
finish up as a part of the program
itself so to begin with uh what we'll
suggest as well also the cust the people
who have already a part have joined the
program page and are a part of the
program already for them we have
recommended to just go through those
introduction to space omix lesson in the
bytes and molecules uh course and also
go ahead with the course or introduction
to bioinformatics so that if you are
from a non-bioinformatics background you
get some insights and some understanding
of what the role of bioinformatics is in
uh trans and translational health care
so this is the introductory uh lesson
that i was just talking about space
comics and astronaut health that you are
supposed to just begin with and complete
till the time we have our first session
that is scheduled for 19th of october
right and then you have the other uh
courses as well that you are supposed to
complete asynchronously as a part of the
program
now once your uh
courses are complete the asynchronous
ones and also once your sessions are
complete you would be able to find the
certificate on your profile
now when i talk about profile first of
all it's very very important that you
have an updated profile that is you have
an updated profile picture your name
should be in title case because that's
the
same uh way your name would be
highlighted on the certificates so
please don't write your name in gaps or
in small letters it should be entitled
case also there would be many people who
might not uh
like want to begin with a specialized
social space comics now but would like
to join later so for them you can just
explore the portal and start with the
the courses first of all and then go
ahead with the basic subscription so
that gives you the access to the start
lessons on the
portal itself in the courses
so it's important for you to have an
updated profile and when you complete
those courses you will have your
certificates in the profile section
itself and you can simply download the
certificates from him
also it's important that you connect
your social media account
and why it's important because we do
feature people uh participants based on
their progress so we would be just going
through your progress here on the back
end and monitor it and we would
definitely feature you uh seeing your
progress right and also it's important
that you put a brief bio about yourself
so we do know about you all and those
people who have already joined the
program please make sure that you have
the space omix badge here
under your profile tab so having this
badge uh gives you a sense that you are
a part of the program page and you will
get the access to all the zoom session
links and also the recordings of the
sessions that will be uploaded on the
page
right and here in the courses tab you
will be able to just look at the courses
that you have started with and what
you're working on right now and then
take up the certificate so that was what
i wanted to share with and now if you
have any doubts please ask in the
comments section so that we can just
guide you through and you can also mail
us at the mail id that i've given it
also we have an alternate mail id that
is marketing at the atomicslogic.com
and we would be happy to guide you
through the process
thank you so much subraji and delara it
was great to have you both uh here and
we are looking forward to your sessions
in the program and also i would like to
thank you all for being a part of the
webinar today and we will we would be
definitely looking forward to meet you
all on 19th as well
thank you everyone have